[Music]
hi I'm Jolene and this is like a
property investor
[Music]
there's a family living in a house so
it's a it's a month
I'm just got four children and it's full
into I wouldn't say
total disrepair but it definitely needs
a lot of love and attention so we're
going to go into it and with them we're
going to completely refurbish all so the
way that we normally approach a project
is to look at it with a fairly good idea
of what we're doing so we look at the
roof first to make sure that's not
leaking so the roof needs a couple of
repairs done on it on it there's no damp
coming up from the ground so there's no
damp course needed which is cool the
electrics the next thing that we look at
because electrics might really mean
chiseling away the wall and rewiring
completely where we're not entirely sure
as to what state the electrics are in we
know it needs a new consuming unit and
we know that some of the some of the
work needs looking at so until we
actually get the keys to the property we
can't think much deeper but we've
allowed for that in our refurb the gas
at the moment is a gas cooker we're
going to take that I spoke with the oven
talent who we'll be meeting later and
she's happy that it's an electric cooker
and my preference is as a landlord put
in electric so the only gas coming into
the premises is the boil is the boiler
it makes it a lot safer for the tandem
which is good so we're going to do did
the gas so they were offering to the
property at two o'clock we're going to
meet Cheryl the local the tenant at the
moment have a cat with her because I
very much worked in cohorts with her
because if you're going to do work on a
property and she's going to be staying
in it then why not get her involved as
much as possible as to its design and
the house laid out so it's a
three-bedroom property with a dining
room and a lounge so to reception rooms
and a little utility room it was quite
full of junk I think because it hadn't
been looked after as it should have been
the tenant sort of fell out of love with
it so the idea is very much to clear it
so which is what Cheryl's been working
well
the last couple of days we've then got
the Builder coming around about four
o'clock with the kitchen designer so we
can work through everything with them
and then sort of get a detailed schedule
of works done for the next next four
weeks welcome to the house so that'd be
a new front door and showers asked for
no glass panel so hopefully there'll be
no glass panel right the first
impression is it's quite tired well so I
out the electrics which was thought out
and lights quite early on we'll put a
brand new radiator over there and then
we'll just redecorate getting rid of the
feature wall here so just make
everything brilliant white so the door
just actually falls off in my hands
so we've bring in a brand new kitchen
the sink you can see outside at the
moment there's loads of water that goes
over the front drive and that's because
the pipes broken so we'll be putting in
a new pipe for that as well so in the
lounge we're gonna potentially take off
the wooden bottom mid wall I'm going to
take out the fireplace take out the fire
the UM setting on the floor so the floor
goes all the way to the wall
plus the ceiling and then take off all
the wallpaper again and then brilliant
white throughout back in along the
corridor so they've asked for laminate
flooring throughout
apart from on the stairs and apart from
in the master bedroom so work that's
exactly what we're going to do they've
got um four children sit five six nine
and ten
so quite young the girls are
experimenting with makeup and things so
off laminate floor it's a lot easier to
get nail varnish off then off a carpet
that so that sir channels wish rather
than me dictating it's no entire
bathroom so that will be totally ripped
up and a brand new bathroom put in so
new toilet new sink new bath new shower
and then a towel rail as well and it
will be tiled probably be a white brick
tile which looks really tiny which is
brilliant news um new fan so as you can
see us worried in there for a few years
but you need to have it for ventilation
it's a legal requirement these days for
a rented property bedroom number one
which is one of the children's bedrooms
so okay that'll be lovely to floor in
the corner up on the ceiling you can see
where there's been condensation because
the windows don't have any vents in them
to allow air to circulate so think here
will either be replacing the window or
putting in vents and depending on the
state of the window when we inspect
their bit closer we'll be taking off the
feature wall paper and then just be
plastering the ceiling and everything
will be brilliant white so yeah it
should be a good bedroom for two little
girls while looking for things so again
all the wall the wall plate that's
coming off to the two walls and when the
tenants move out all that will be left
is the furniture and everything else
will will be boxed up for us to look at
but either put it into storage or put it
into what pay room and then decorate
that lost should be good the worst thing
in this room is the small window just
behind Matt is some the window does on
the shop so in the winter the bands have
to go and with the mum to keep warm all
that light so that obviously needs
replacing so we'll be doing that
otherwise this room we've lost the
ceiling
get rid of the wallpaper and then read
that great brilliant
why throw up so yeah be a nice little
bedroom how long have you been in this
house em7 six or seven year and then I
guess you've been cut you had to
maintain it yourself pretty much to you
as much yeah
you're saying about it you thought were
your father dad we don't just to come
into a while the decorating for us
before we got Polys or drank keep on top
right now what's this hard work
yep yep so what bit if we when we reefer
that you the most looking for to the
kitchen a nice kitchen
I hear the kitchen I've tried my hardest
and that look nice but it just doesn't
work
I hear that yeah yeah well I thought I'm
really on fault that you've been moving
our going on whole day for a week
yeah buttons and then you mean moving in
with this system yeah three weeks yeah
it so you'll be able to come have a look
every now and then up everybody's
passing every day and go out to work
just lives just let you around the
corner ha super yeah I'll be good yeah
smoking awesome cool keep the guys on
there on that oh he's okay yeah at the
manor staple I'm trying to keep stuff
nice meself but it's like I see every
day is hard when you haven't got nice
stuff to keep it nice you know and then
I'll buy new furniture and trying to map
the hill slope nice or it would just be
a lot easier just to have it nice to
keep it nice of that make sense and then
it would it would be it just a lot
easier even at the minute I could I
didn't even let the bands bring the
friends around because I see enough not
will see at the hosts in it's not fair
on them the carnet I've knee buddy round
and so I'll just be Mikado or life's
easier really
[Music]
electric cooker the electric off yeah
washing machine will go down in the
right hand corner or we open lock is
Robin
yeah all right yeah yeah yeah fringe
will stay where it is double dog will
stay where's yeah yeah run of units
they're the same source style here so
three units up high just a false wall
yeah thank behind this suddently Scott
Lee our soil yep like a really tight
pipeline the idea refurb in four weeks
so because shelter living there she goes
well holiday week one then for three
weeks she'll be living with her sister
and then should be coming back into a
bright sparkly house so she the cloggers
[Music]